ball utah now their bench is just two
out of 12 from beyond the arc
ross throw it down
throw it down russ
down the middle he goes then he gets a
technical for taunting but
i mean he looked back and rudy gobert
and handsome
with some words that was so clear that's
what russ
has been known for doing though getting
into the paint and then exploding did he
ever explode
over the top of gobert
oh wow that's just a monster dunk
by russell westbrook
[Applause]
this is one of those where you say
i'll live with that technical
[Applause]
that was monster type that has
lit this crowd up
wow
and that was a trampoline act there
by
russell westbrook i mean this is what
we've seen his entire career we always
talk about everything's predicated on
his explosiveness to the rim
it's been a frustrating year he's taken
a ton
a ton of criticism so far this year
650 left hawks ball out
the timeout cooper on the lob and up top
the john collins what a play
holy smokes did john collins get up in
the air
what
look at this pass john goes up
[Applause]
even the cavalier bench it looked like
he couldn't believe it shoulders
i mean he gets jared allen
out of the way allen found him john's
got a three-point play the oohs and oz
and state farm oh my goodness
mobley oh smothered by jaron loose ball
picked up by the grizzlies melted
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my goodness
goodness i thought melton had thrown
this and no way you get it
morant again catches it
watch this he's behind him he catches
the partner throws it down
full extension by morance timeout
cavaliers
the metal's got 11. miles has got 12 and
the rip away what do you got miles
bridges
oh i'll take it oh i'll take two even
give me that james harden
miles a little sunday service
[Music]
[Applause]
360. did man zach ravine get mad
exactly he can't do that he can't do
that
the signature dunk of the season from
the mean his frustrations got the best
of him he got teamed up but this place
is lit 14-point lead
started out
nine and four
there's a cut to the basket defense
inside once again okoro disrupted on his
way to the rim
great hands by porzingis early on
[Applause]
blows out porzingis
[Applause]
with the good defense good awareness on
the inside
over zealous closeout and alan
got allen that time
to see tony back working i know it warms
all of our hearts in the nba family to
see him back doing his thing
as toscano anderson wanted to honor tony
with an emphatic throwdown
four three in and out rose with the
outlet pass here comes topping oh
wow
yeah how sweet it is
it's teammates engulfed with him
but this is what topping gives the
knicks energy
and getting out in transition so an
excellent job there
r.j barrett ahead here's obi topping
look out
a christmas steady gift
burying merry christmas
speaking of cooking how about this
little fire from ob topping
and a highlight to the next christmas
day win we'll be back in a moment from
the garden
[Music]
hole in the drive drops it off to jalen
smith
with the poster on plumly and i don't
care if he's going to get a taunting
foul or not i don't care
i don't care and neither does anybody
over on that bench
seven-point game warriors with a lead
thompson just the two points
oh
exploding to the rim
clay thompson powers one down
acl injury was the left leg the achilles
the right achilles
goes off that left leg this time he's
got plenty of explosion here he
certainly does and he knows
against this cleveland cavalier team if
you're going to go to the rim that's the
way you've got to go
strong and steph curry
loves him
out of the arc
rush throw it down
throw it down russ
down the middle he goes then he gets a
technical for taunting getting into the
paint and then exploding did he ever
explode
over the top of gobert
oh wow that's just a monster dunk
by russell westbrook
this is one of those where you say